well this begs a question has hip hop
gone woke I spoke to Ben about his
unlikely transformation into a rap
heavyweight yesterday and today I'm
joined by the artist who actually
crafted the song Tom McDonald Tom well
first of all congratulations on this
runaway Smash Hit um you actually
entitled to celebrate it because you are
a Bonafide rapper Ben I'm not quite so
convinced by maybe a one hit wonder um
first of all are you surprised by the
backlash or did you predict the backlash
and that was one of the reasons you did
the song in the first
place uh well I've made a lot of sort of
anti-woke anthems over the years and
there's always a certain degree of
backlash that comes with it um so this
one was sort of you know a lot of my
relationship with the audience is call
and response I make a song people
respond in the way that they do uh and
then I respond again with the next song
so uh you know facts with Ben is sort of
the cap on a long line of anti-woke
anthems that have been met with pretty
heavy criticism people uh in the uh the
black RAP Community have come out and
said that this is just blatant cultural
appropriation racism because you're
accusing all their music that they
produce of being about selling drugs
pushing guns stripper poles turning a
Sons into Thugs and so on what do you
say to that
criticism um I think that there's you
know there's all types of rappers out
there there's there's black rappers and
white rappers and Asian rappers and
Indian rappers all types of rappers and
I don't think that uh criticizing sort
of the status quo of the genre or
criticizing the prevalent content of the
music I don't I don't I don't agree that
there's anything racist about that what
struck me is that there seems to have
been more outrage over you guys
lampooning uh this style of rap music
than there is about the actual rap music
which often to me gets an extraordinary
pass from criticism and I said to Ben
yesterday when you have John Legend
rewriting Baby it's cold outside because
it's so offensive um but doesn't rewrite
any of the lyrics of any of his rap
friends there's an obvious double
standard yeah absolutely um I think that
sort of in general um over the last 10
to 15 years there's been uh very
prevalent themes in Hip Hop you know
sort of uh objectifying women and and
and glorifying violence and
romanticizing drug abuse and stuff like
that and um I think that hip hop likes
to think of itself as quite a woke genre
and uh none of those things seem to
quite align with uh what the the woke
mob um is is standing up and being vocal
again so I you know I think it it's a
little bit hypocritical but you know do
you think you can be number one on the
billboard chart or do you think you may
get subtly shadowbound to stop you
getting there
uh well it's happened before I've had
billboard refuse to count my album sales
um I'm completely independent there's no
record label there's no distribution
there's no marketing team nothing I make
all of my Beats I write all the songs My
Girlfriend shoots the music videos
entirely independent of the music
industry uh so you know censorship
suppression Shadow Banning very familiar
with all of those things like I said
Billboards refus to count my album sales
before they've removed me off trending
charts on YouTube um my Distribution
Company Toon Core which is supposed to
be the alternative for artists who don't
want to sign a major record deal that
they are supposed to be able to go to
ton and independently release their own
music um so I had ton cor deny release
of this song and say that they will not
host it in any form uh because of quote
unquote lyrical content um so you know I
think I think the buzz is there and I
think the Press is there and I think
that the the proof is in the pudding I
have access to the sales numbers as do
many other people um so I think it would
be pretty hard for billboard at this
point in time to just uh blatantly um
snub us on the Billboard charts can you
make one promise finally Tom which is if
you do get there you don't make as part
of your celebration a decision to do a
whole album with Ben Shapiro I don't
think any of us could stomach
that absolutely make that promise I can
absolutely make that promise
uh Tom congratulations on a success I
love the record because I love I I see
what you're doing with it and I applaud
you for it it's sending up a lot of
double standard and I think that's
important uh thanks for coming on the
show appreciate it thanks for having me
Pierce okay we heard from uh Tom and now
let's he from The Hip Hop establishment
joining me now from New York who the
highly respected rapper talb Kali who
also co-hosts the midnight Miracle
podcast with Dave Chappelle and the DJ
and digital media Mogul DJ Vlad well a a
very high-powered panel to respond so
let me start with you then uh tal you
and I have locked horns before on
Twitter as it used to be used to Twitter
I think we both like to express
ourselves forcefully and absolutely no
problem in doing that what is what is
your objection to this
song well first of all um forgive my
voice because I'm coming off tour my
voice sounds a little scratchy I want
congratulate Tom okay cool I want to
congratulate Tom uh McDonald on his
journey and surb
um because that's very important to note
that part of his story is about his
journey and sobriety I do think is very
cowardly and very racist to blame Hip
Hop for his addiction um as if white
people don't have addiction issues
that's first and foremost but if we're
going to talk about the song Facts uh
with Ben Shapiro let's have a facts
versus feelings conversation which is
something that Ben Shapiro always says
um the hook of the song is this ain't
rap which I agree with it's not rap it's
not hip-hop has nothing to do with a rap
Pierce you're wrong the song is not has
nothing to do with rap um this song he
says money cars Clos we ain't selling
drugs we ain't going to overdose we
ain't pushing guns we're we ain't
promoting stripper poles we won't turn
your sons into thgs and your daughters
in the ho this is not facts he
completely erased allc conscious hip-hop
you see I got this shirt from Tribe
Called Quest one of the greatest rap
groups of all time he erased what I do
he erased what my comp my what my people
do and uh most of my friends don't rap
about those things Tom is lying about
yeah hang on okay all right yeah but
hang on hang on I'm Al I don't think
he's saying all rappers do he made a
point of saying he doesn't mean all
rappers or all hip-hop stars but there's
no doubt there's no doubt some do
there's no doubt some do that he made a
point of course of course and there's
some country music artist and come heavy
metal artists that participate in
violent and sexual content but I would
never make a song you know what I'm
saying like he didn't specify that he
meant some rap in the song He specified
that on your show when you question him
but on the song he's saying I'm trying
to be offensive and I I'm hoping to
upset people so guess what as a black
man black man who does hip-hop I'm
offended if you were trying to offend me
well then you good you did a good job to
claim that rap or art is a cause of
violence and or cause of addiction in
his life is irresponsible and
hypocritical when a bomb drops in a in a
nation it falls on the just and the
unjust I watched a movie called
Oppenheimer last night about a white man
who made an atomic bomb that dropped on
Japanese people because another white
man genocided 6 million Jewish people
killers of the flower moon is a movie
about a great movie about a white man
white men who go and and and pillage and
steal from Native American people uh
yesterday a trump fan from Philly uh
decapitated his father because his
father was voting for Joe Biden that's
like vanilla Isis you can't tell me that
in the culture that he claims that he
stands for that there's no violence in
sex you can't tell me that anyone who
supports Trump like Tom McDonald does in
his music after Trump's mug shot after
January 6 after this man has been
indicted for rape and has 91 felonies
you can't tell me about blue lives
matter you can't tell me that you about
Law and Order you're being a hypocrite
okay powerful words uh DJ Vlad You' been
sitting there patiently uh what do you
make of all
this I mean I agree uh some with t quy
who's also a friend of mine um the
problem is is that when you talk about
rap and you want to talk about the the
gangster lyrics the violent lyrics The
Drug lyrics when you look at rap as a
whole when you look at the biggest
rappers in the world right now Drake
jcole Kendrick Lamar these guys aren't
rapping about drugs they're not talking
about violence they're not talking about
uh you know beating women or whatever
else and I think a lot of times when you
have these songs that try to generalize
these types of things you know it kind
of it oversimplifies things and it gives
rap in general a bad name you know so
it's kind of annoying and you know
listening to the song you know on face
value it doesn't sound like like he's
really saying anything wrong but a lot
of times when you have these these sort
of white supremacist type of sayings
like for example all lives matter you
know from the outside looking in of
course all lives matter but it's really
a shot at black lives matter and kind of
trying to undermine that type of thing
so I really don't like you know what we
call in hip-hop sneak dissing and I feel
the song has a lot of sneak dissing
Telly would it be fair to say that hip
hop has moved to a you know for one of a
better word a better place that it not
it the biggest stars no longer want to
rap about stuff that caused all the
offense and actually it's changed is
that is that accurate see see I don't
think that this should be a conversation
with three white people and one black
person about the state of Hip Hop and a
referendum on hip hop I think that's the
wrong direction to go one more thing I'm
GNA say about Donald Trump is that Tom
McDonald is an immigrant Donald Trump
just said immigrants are poisoning our
blood here in America Donald Trump uses
uh white nationalist rhetoric from mind
conf and Hitler all the time and this
guy is a supporter of his song T hang
listen you can have your views about
Donald Trump that's fine and and by the
way you can say I said I'm done I'm done
with that I'm done with that I'm done
with that that's why I was going to the
I get it but the idea that I'm not
allowed to or V DJ vad isn't allowed to
comment about hip hop or rap is
ridiculous I didn't say that I didn't
say basically D Vlad no I didn't let me
let me be clear DJ Vlad is a
controversial figure in our culture a
lot of people accuse him of being a
culture vulture that is not
a criticism that I personally agree with
although I do understand the argument I
work with if unbeknownst to a lot of
people I've done more songs with white
rappers that any rapper you can name any
black rapper you can name my next thing
goes featureing M uh MC Miller rest in
peace I've work with M lore I work with
ar the rugged Man there's no problem
with white people in hip-hop there's a
problem with racist white people in
hip-hop and Tom McDonald song is racist
and is factually incorrect and I could
and I could break down what's factually
incorrect in the song facts and I could
break down how bench
started his career by saying rap rap
isn't music so you got somebody featured
on your song who tweeted in 2019 fact
rap isn't music and if you think it is
you're stupid well that person is
clearly not an anti-racist intelligent
person Tom McDonald owes the hip-hop
community and apology for putting
someone on a song that in TW 20 2009
writing for a white nationalist uh site
Breitbart wrote an article saying rap is
crap these people don't respect hip-hop
Tom McDonald is making rap for people
think you're missing I look I I played
some of this stuff back to Ben Shapiro
yesterday I think you're slly missing
the point he's he's
lampooning the world of rap and hipop
I'm not missing the point think there's
a lot of hypocrisy and double standard
there I'm very clear that Ben Shapiro is
is lampooning hip hop I'm very clear
about that I'm not I'm not under any
look even you must admit when John
Legend goes out of his way to rewrite
the lyrics to Baby its cold outside
because of the me too campaign cuz he's
he thinks it's about sexual assault but
doesn't rewrite any lyrics from any
hip-hop or rap song in the last 50 years
you got to admit there is a ridiculous
double standard there isn't there I
totally I couldn't I couldn't disagree
more I completely disagree because I
think you removing all I think you're
removing all social political and
historical context that goes into
creating hip hop and equating it with
the social political context you
genuinely think baby is cold outside is
is more offensive than anything that the
that imp I didn't say that I said no I
didn't imply it I said you are removing
context to make a false equivalency the
context is very straight forward John
Legend chose to rewrite the lyrics of
baby it's but he didn't rewrite any of
the offensive misogynist violent lyrics
of his friends in the rap World Pi I get
I get that that's how you feel but
you're feeling it's not a feeling it's a
fact and the facts is oh no that's not
well it's it's not a fact that it's a
it's a fact that John Legend hasn't
Rewritten any lyrics of people in the
not Pierce Morgan John Legend is not
your slave he doesn't have to do what
he's not my slave but he can be a
hypocrite and he was then then let's
stop talking about John Legend because
this is not about John Legend let's talk
about the song Facts stop deflecting
stop deflecting and let's talk about the
song Facts okay okay so can we get back
toang let me let me bring in DJ
Vlad T there's three of us here let me
bring in DJ Vlad you apparently DJ V
you're a culture vulture what does that
mean first of all uh
uh I mean from my point of view I think
that's a slang for pretty much any white
person in hip-hop I've seen every
prominent white person in hip-hop being
called a culture vulture from Steve
riffkin to leor Cohen to Eminem also
also black people get called culture
vultures also black people get C culture
vultures and this cult culture so it
doesn't it's not it's not skin skin
color specific you can be a black or
white culture V right okay it's not
absolutely am I culture vulture but but
white people do get it white people do
get a little heavier than others and
I've never minded being that's right
because white people that's that's
exactly that's exactly right because
white people are the dominant group
that's how it goes racism is not logical
or convenient for anybody sorry well I
mean why people AR the dominant group in
hang on hang on white people are not the
dominant group in music anymore I would
say most of the bigest stars in the
world right now are not people own all
of the record companies white people own
all of the record companies peers that's
true well I had that conversation with
10 years I had that conversation Kanye
and he felt very strongly about it and I
had that conversation with him and he he
may have a point about
that white people own all of the but it
doesn't change the fact that many of the
biggest and most successful and richest
music artists in the world right now are
black that is also true all right well
let's CH let's change places how about
we get all the money and y'all get to
tap dance how about that I don't think
you're short of a few Bob are
you what' you say I don't think you're
short of a few few Bob as we'd say in
England you've got a few dollars up your
sleeve um it does the money is not is
not about is not about whether or not
one individual makes it I am an
exception to the rule the vast majority
of my people are not rich people and
that's a fact and I'm exception to the
rule because I make money doing
conscious underground hip hop I'm not
doing pop hip hop I'm not appealing to a
magga fan base I'm not I'm not I don't
rap about materialism misogyny I don't
do any of that so I'm the exception to
the rule Ty it's good to have you on the
program come back I've enjoyed this
debate hold on hold on hold on I want I
want to I want to okay but I want to I
want to say that Ben Ben Shapiro has a
history of racist comments and for Tom
McDonald you know what list okay well
then y' y'all should acknowledge that
okay you said your you said your bit uh
DJ thank you for coming back on please
come again soon I enjoyed that debate
thank you very
much